[Music]
well the number of new
daily coronavirus infections in tokyo
has gone above 5000 for the first time
ever cases in the olympics host city are
rising
faster than ever fuelled by the more
contagious delta variant
more widely japan's government has
extended emergency measures to eight
more regions here's the data from johns
hopkins university this is the last 30
days in tokyo alone so 30 days ago we
were looking at approximately 500 new
cases a day
when the games started around 900
bringing us now
two weeks later to the point where there
are 5 000 plus
cases a day and then more widely this
is japan not just tokyo the whole
country since the start
of the year and just as a point of
reference
the olympic games began at this point
and i think the graph kind of tells the
story uh past
that andy richardson our correspondent
in tokyo it was not long ago
andy that olympics organizers were
saying that their games had nothing to
do with the rising cases across japan it
would be hard to argue that now
they are going to try and argue though i
can assure you uh kamal i mean
you were putting those figures into some
sort of context i was standing here last
week saying
figures in tokyo have hit 3000 um for
the first time that was a new record
then and the fact we've hit 5000 today
shows just how quickly
um this situation is escalating the
state of emergency uh just a few days
ago was extended
um here in tokyo until at least uh the
end of the month from
from a sporting perspective if that
really matters and that was going to
have an impact on the paralympic games
because there had been hopes that
spectators and fans could be allowed in
for the start of the paralympics
there's still a chance that that could
be the situation for the last few days
of that event but it all looks
um increasingly unlikely now and i think
there is a growing sense of frustration
amongst many people here we've spoken to
the vaccination rollout was slow the
back story there is that in the 1990s
the japanese government was hit with a
number of libel cases and was found
liable for side effects from other
inoculations so it was a very cautious
rollout of the vaccine and that's now
having an impact with this new
delta variants uh surging all over the
country it's not
just an issue in tokyo it is all over
the country and i think
the state of emergency itself is is a
bit of an oxymoron because it's it's not
a law or an order it is a request for
people to perhaps stay at home work from
home if they can
it's a request for restaurants to close
early and perhaps not surprisingly
um people are maybe not adhering to
those requests
when that same government is also
carrying on with the olympics
andy can you give us any indication of
what things are like actually in the
olympic village which
is really supposed to be the heart of
the bubble which is supposed to keep
this virus contained
that's right i mean every day you will
hear
the high number of screening tests
they've done the low number of positive
cases
and they will repeat that there is no
link no provable link between
the athletes village and what is
happening there and and the wider surges
in tokyo and around the rest of the
country there were 31 new cases
today what's interesting about
the breakdown of that number is that 23
were residents
of tokyo residents of japan either
working as contractors or volunteers
they're not staying in the athletes
village so this idea that there's
no chance of there being a link between
a positive case
in the village and in the wider
community is increasingly difficult
to maintain they say that
it's a big tv event the olympics and
it's actually encouraging people to
follow the state of emergency because of
the high tv ratings and it's encouraging
people to stay at home rather than go
out because obviously
no fans are allowed at the venues but
there is a frustration
there's a frustration amongst
epidemiologists not just amongst the
public
um that at a time when uh
the delta variant is surging that the
fact the games are going on is sending
out the wrong message it's sending out a
message of
optimism that you can relax and people
aren't
aware because of the fact the olympics
are going on just how serious
the situation is becoming in tokyo and
in in the wider country as well
andy richardson with that update from
the olympic games host city tokyo thank
you
we'll stay in asia